so today I'm gonna yeah I'm super happy
to be here thank you
the organizers for letting me talk about
Bayesian models late in the afternoon or
in yeah yeah so today I'm gonna talk
about work I did with a colleague of
mine
so yeah the good stuff is probably his
and if something's really shouldn't be
like the way it is presented work yeah
so yeah I'm just gonna start today and
talk about a little bit about the
company I'm working for calling all
Lenovo and then a little bit about
forecasting B to C so our private users
private customers demand and then some
technical challenges in the in the
abstract and I will talk to my or I
wrote about pitfalls but that sounds
little gloom and so yeah I'm gonna talk
about I'm gonna call it technical
challenges yeah so clean all means
grocery store in the region so probably
so that's all I have to explain that it
is online store but in order to make
this online grocery store work yeah
grocery industry has really low margins
especially in Norway and yeah it's quite
expensive to distribute to people in
Norway so in order to do make this we
have to build the most efficient retail
system in the world more or less and we
do that by building everything ourselves
so you see okay the robots we didn't
actually build those those are from ABB
I think but everything kind of more or
less telling the robots what to do and
all where else they're all logistics
everything else mostly in Python which
is good for me as a data scientist
working in Python so the company is
doing the same
yeah today I'm gonna talk about a little
part of what we do so I'm part of the
data team as you see which is kind of
serving the whole company where I'm
today today I'm embedded in the online
store a customer facing part of the
business so why am i doing forecasting
just because I'm working a lot on what
the customers do which is can be a good
thing when you want to forecast what
they do yeah
so reducing uncertainty about the demand
is really important for us you can think
that when we order groceries they have a
short shelf life but their shelf life of
someone turning up for a shift is a lot
shorter it's only that shift so if you
miss miss the demand of that day you
kind of waste people so to say by golly
meant to shift then they have nothing to
do or you have to close the store to say
okay we don't have the capacity so you
advertise a lot and then people show up
for ya pick up their phones and to order
and then you can't you can't serve them
because you have to close the store so
this is really important we have to also
have to order enough cars or trucks
derive the world is round we know need
to know when we have to book those
course so why Bayesian except for that's
what the cool kids in the Statistics
Department use which is true but maybe
not too good reason to spend my work I
was doing that so yeah main reason is
that it's hard to model the demand
precisely so we talked a lot to the
people doing the actual planning and I
found out that if you can give them
lower and an upper estimate and what we
believe is our possible outcomes they
can plan around planned around that we
can use our workforce more efficiently
so we can know we plan for the maximum
for instance if we want to keep the
store open and then if you don't reach
that we use them for other tasks
but we need to know like how many extra
people are we booking for our putting up
on the shift and the other problem is
that we're really young company and
adding to the problem is that some of
the data and the early days it's it's
hard to use because we had 10% weekly
growth which is like you just have this
hockey stick so it's really hard to time
series models freak outs and then we
know a lot about the process we're
modeling so we can actually start
modeling it instead of trying a time
series models which we did but they
didn't work that well yeah other
advantages is PI M C 3 and other
probabilistic programming tools are
really really good tools for for
building custom models I find at least
so so that's an added bonus and you can
build hierarchical models so we need a
little data and you can you can try to
share effects across segments or areas
or you can you can mobile kind of
holidays as you can you can get some art
typical part of holidays and kind of
mobile and lend your borrow effects from
from some holidays to other holidays and
in Norway people really love their
holidays so they go away for weeks and
you have holidays moving around each
year so so we need really need to do
that
yeah and then the last part we can use
informative Breyers this is really good
for us because some we haven't been
around that long
so some holidays we have never observed
we'd never we don't know what happens
when Christmas hits a Tuesday Christmas
Eve is a Tuesday yeah which is really
problematic because what we observe is
that people have their usual weekly
buying setup and they and then when
Christmas is probably or when Christmas
is on a Sunday they can add all the
Christmas shopping to that week before
right but then as you approach that day
or as that as Christmas moves
in the next week and you suddenly shift
to people then having business as usual
orders on this week and then the
Christmas order next week and we don't
know when that happens so we haven't
been able to move that yet but we can
try modeling kind of scenarios there
yeah another advantage yeah so every
time I present this people tell me is
another person who said this so this is
the but yeah I think it's a really good
quote sometimes sometimes you can't be
exactly right so then it's better to be
vaguely right and not be exactly wrong
yeah
and what that gives us out I'll get more
into how we list but it gives us this so
you can see we have an upper and a lower
band so it's the what's called lowest
here is the first percentile of the
posterior distribution and then the
upper is the 99th and then we have the
10th 90th and then we have the mean in
the middle and then you have the orange
line which is the actual valleys and you
can see where yeah we're inside this
band what we're predicting which is our
goal so yeah this it was like high level
what we built so a little bit more into
driving into why we did this yeah like I
said we're young company so so our time
series are really short standard time
series models we try them didn't work
that well and and adding that we haven't
observed certain combinations of
holidays weekdays and seasons which is a
good reason to to try to build them all
to yourself so is this said it but I
like this small data being models
thinking so if you have a lot of data
you can just I send the data into the
model have some powerful boosting
library or neural net and you're fine
and here we have to model a lot and what
we did is found out that if we if we
break down another shopping behavior
into transitions between our
habet segments I'll get it a little bit
and then we actually just have a
state-space model into time and then we
mobile how many orders we get per
customer in a segment for a day and then
how many units per segment we would do
this in see what I'm drawing here you go
from something that looks like this in
times and to more stable stuff like this
and you have some season the healthy
maybe which is what you want to achieve
achieve especially with time series
models but here you can achieve it by
breaking down the processes yourself
yeah so these are habit segments there
they actually we get them from another
mobile I worked on which is which is a
predictive model that just predicts the
probability of orders in a certain time
period into the future for every
customer in our customer base which is a
quite simple extra boost thing on top of
a really simple future engineering
because we really wanted to be stable
over time and what we get then are just
and these segments were intended for
human consumption so it wasn't intended
to be put into the model but a lot of
what we do is built around these
segments which is also it's a good idea
to use the same segments in the model
because then people we can inspect what
the model gives us and it's related to
the strategies we use and/or implement
and and how we think about a customer
journey yeah so maybe it's easier to see
this how we model is over time when look
at the segments so we we have new n and
the W new and customers so the wimba
customers are customers who have already
ordered have some orders but our that
our model say are inactive and then then
order again while new customers are
customers that I either either
without a new purchase or having
registered and then start purchasing our
paths their first purchase and then we
model how they the transitions between
these states and the habit segments and
once we've done that we can do that from
week zero we know how many have
customers who have a new segment in week
zero and then we can look at transition
transition or we can use the transition
rates to see how many customers we have
in each segment in week one and we can
do that week two three as far as you
want right now we're working on six and
twelve weeks and then you can and then
we model the orders per day per customer
and the units per order and the
customers per customer in each habit
statement so basic way of modeling these
things are the same for different three
different models so these are three
separate models so I'm just going to
talk about the orders per day for a
customer model because it's more or less
the same idea yeah so what we do here is
we then for for this orders per day per
customer we get a posterior distribution
of that and we try to come back to that
we tried using samplers in the beginning
but that took too long so now we're
using variational inference at B in this
case and we built this in prime C 3s is
quite simple set of explanatory
variables we have seasonality variables
we have the weekly variation so we have
Monday Tuesday Wednesday etc we have
long trends short friends we have
holidays special holidays in Norway and
other special events we can model - it
depends how you define a holiday for
instance we have law so this is might be
some pubs but in Norway everybody if you
have a holiday on the Thursday nobody
works on a Friday so
which is quite specific problem maybe
but that means that you get this weird
kind of extra holiday when that happens
and then you have some whole days that
move around and you have the kind of no
we've seen the same faith of May it's
like the fourth of July but nobody works
on 17th of May in Norway so then if you
combine that to it with another holiday
you get this super kind of you get the
Friday and the Tuesday and then nobody
works for a week so yeah so the special
events does it sounds like we don't work
we really I like to say that we're
really efficient when we do work this is
oh yeah and then to make in the
beginning we did this separately for all
the avid segments and every day right so
this was fine for so if we didn't get an
advice by doing that when we started
aggregating but we underestimated the
uncertainty because some effects there
were some effects we didn't capture and
everybody did the same thing at the same
day and our mobile thought that okay
when we like have a high roll from the
posterior from this segment and we
equally probable have a low draw and
another segment so and certainly it was
underestimated the width so now we after
switching to variational inference we
thought wow let's see what happens if we
put all the days and all the segments
into one or they in so the with all the
error terms and have a one huge matrix
where they can correlate and we're like
a little like this and but it worked
really well so we thought so that made
our model yeah so then we had like a
little over a thousand random variables
in our model and which is not what I
intended in beginning but it works so
yeah it looks like this we have a lot of
posteriors comes out of this model and
once we have that we can just draw from
all these four series and we can
simulate the system we want and then we
get the plus I showed you earlier where
we have a band of demand which we think
will be inside
yeah so yeah so I was little uncertain
know how how high-level and low-level I
should go because it's easy to kind of
over fit to someone in the audience but
then maybe the accuracy was a little low
now so yeah I apologize if I'm not
detailed enough or too detailed and not
detailed enough at the same time but
yeah I'm gonna talk a little bit about
the main gains from using this model
before diving into some of the problems
yeah
so we had significant efficiency gains a
little hard to quantify according to the
ones quantifying the gains and should
probably been me but we're moving quite
fast so we're doing a lot of stuff at
the same time which is really really not
a good idea if I want to quantify one
thing but everybody's really really
happy with the officials against
especially at the Manning process in at
the warehouse
yeah another good thing is that all the
stakeholders plan according to and the
same so we avoid some problems of of
someone taking measures to have enough
flexibility in the system was other
don'ts so you kind of pay the price the
insurance price you can say of having a
lot of people throw up and then you
don't have enough cars so the other way
around right so now everybody can be on
the same page and what what do you think
is that kind of the maximum amount of
orders on a day or the minimum and then
because we do this instead of more
manual process we spend a lot less time
discussing what's why we why the
forecast and they can spend more time
talking about how to plan for for their
predictions they get and I should say
something about when you should not do
this to be fair if mobile works really
well so because it's it's a lot more
time consuming and there's some other
problems with these models so if you can
just
do some peach engineering maybe with
some automatic heat engineering library
and then you just run like three
different boosting library boosting
models on top of it and and sample and
you're fine right and you don't need the
uncertainty if you're accurate right if
you're always on target then who cares
right and another reason is you might
not have you in other cases you might
get an uncertainty estimate or you get
the ban outright but you can do anything
with it so why would you need it then in
that case go for the just go for the
most likely estimate and use a different
model and then maybe if you have a
really large amount of mounted data so
there there are some ways of doing this
on bigger data sets but yeah there are
you might run into problems which we
don't have and then this is more like
motivational it's from advertising why
you should order instead of going to the
store with your tired kid that's a
kindergarten but it's also yeah just
some of the technical problems we faced
and we had to add this all and there are
a lot of them so I just took a little I
made a little selection and then we can
to grab a beer and dive into all the
stuff that went wrong and I can tell you
about it yeah so the model is enormous
so how do you specify model where over a
thousand random variables that's one
problem and then before switching to
variational inference it took 15 hours
to run all the models which is a long
time especially well if you wanna
iterate on specification I can you can
go on for weeks and that's before we
actually just started doing cool stuff
with the ER keys and all the shared
error terms and that stuff yeah so this
is I have to say I really like the
documentation prime C documentation and
there are a lot of really good blog
posts out there
so when you read this it looks it's easy
to read and like I like specifying the
model this way problem is is to be fair
as I a lot of these thousand variables
are from this is from come from the
error terms but still you need a way to
specify all all the random variables
without thousand lines of code right so
this is the first iteration which yeah
this is a production code where we have
to say this is fairly brittle stuff
right so we made dictionaries of random
variables and we got these dictionaries
from the same way after because until
recently there wasn't you have to use
Tiano tensors to know Tiano shared
variables to get the data in and out of
the model and we and we used we had
dictionaries with those and then we just
put random variables on top of that too
and use the same name but you can write
like whole week wrong then it doesn't
understand anything so it's brittle yeah
so what we're doing now is is building
more know so this is the wrong slide so
this is actually no no this is the one
exactly so what we're doing now is
building a mobile class and trying to
clean that stuff up but I'm not showing
you this is almost like this bumper
stickers and other cars a Ferrari so my
pull request is a model class but yeah
we're doing that that's where yeah so
and I didn't think about that problem
before starting this right just just
building a code base that you can
understand this a problem when they get
big models like this and yeah the big
problem with the 15 hour runtime
training time and then we my colleague
and I and another colleague who's not
working on this we did okay we need to
do a hackathon to build this thing into
other way and then it was like 10
minutes okay this works but now so
that's which was super smooth
maybe because the way we've got a little
bit lucky that we modeled this thing the
right way so we didn't have any
multimodal things in there that can blow
up because they'll do things like okay
you need it goes in here and if it's a
multi mobile distribution it'll still
try to fit this one nice bell curve
right so the switch might be not that
smooth if you have a model if you
haven't modeled the process yeah really
well and then another problem how do you
monitor this thing so how do you know if
oddly has converged why is this a
problem I'll get back to that and then
how to evaluate mobile so from the books
and from my other experiences I look at
the posterior predicted these plots and
see how the data fits into that but if
you have a thousand random variables you
can't do that so first ugly yeah we have
problems with the standard convergence
check it never converging converged and
we have some theories why a large number
of parameters is one problem so there's
always something that can is moving
around and probably some collinearity in
there so the model was not getting any
better who's like yanking one thing up
and the other thing down and doing that
in this huge space and then yeah never
it's never finished right so but I'm see
really nice
we took the callback stand a callback
class and we built or like something
built this lost convergence thing and
that works really well so it just looks
at loss and and stops reasonable time
without worrying about how the
parameters inside the model is how
they're moving around yeah and then what
do we do with the posterior predicted
plots yeah so we started out instead of
looking at what we did when developing
we we're looking at the separate
but then we went over to just looking at
the entire system and see how it
actually performs and then our predict
and what we told all the stakeholders to
is we're not looking for we're not
looking for the best point estimate
we're looking for like the data should
be inside this this ban and we're
working to get this band smaller or
narrow narrow overtime right so the
insurance cost goes down you can say
yeah so I had to take stuff out here but
this is something we did or still do
where we kind of plot a lot of
statistics and we can actually also look
at the plots and see how like where
we're missing where some data point so
you can actually use this to see if or
someday so really consistently bad but
this is still kind of time consuming and
hard to because you can say okay we some
biases okay so one of the models run a
long time a little bias because it was
performed okay and then we didn't get
like two wide estimates but we're now
now looking into putting or using this
more trying to find a single metric to
evaluate prediction intervals on the
data points and this is one method night
thing and a not process and Raftery from
in a paper from 2007 looks really
promising yeah because it would be a lot
easier if you have one metric that we
trust and to run different also
monitored over time and less time
consuming so we can do other stuff so
yeah and recently we there was a
published paper on the energy boost
boosting library with answer probably
stay cure more uncertainty in trolls
from Stanford labs I think quite
recently and
that to get with this you may be any
closer to boosting library actually
during this time we need to do without
but we'll see so yeah thank you and I
can take some questions and and we're
hiring we have some we have some data on
or empirical proof proof that we have
people from the US that working at us so
yeah some of you might like to go to
Norway yeah good question because and we
just modeled weird model the weekly
model in the beginning because that is
what we as humans looking at the data do
making decisions we're comfortable using
right so we inherited that from the
older process so yeah we might we should
probably have shorter intervals but it's
still it's not most customers purchase
goods weekly or bi-weekly so we wouldn't
be updated that much faster anyway but
yeah good question it's just yeah we
inherited it from the no-no-no so we
estimated the transition probabilities
between the segment so we just got the
like the segment's as if they were true
data you know like yeah so and we used
quite wide priors just modeling orders
directly
yeah it cleaned up a lot in so we see in
the beginning what we saw was that these
segments behaved really the same over
time or last year's but the kind of
effect on the man was driven by the
composition of both of these segments
like in the beginning we have a lot of
people kind of getting used to the
product moving through the segments oh
yeah and reason for choosing it in the
beginning was that this these segments
are the same segments that marketing
team for instance are targeting when
they tried to kind of increase sales for
instance right so an idea here is that
we can actually go in and manipulate
those so we haven't used done that yet
but that is a reason for using segments
that it's more like your question I
should have said something but no right
now it goes to a dashboard and then they
they do the planning and the week so my
dream here is actually that we we just
get really good loss function on how
much like the cost of going over and
under so under budget less efficient
operation and over budget you have just
closed store for instance right and then
if you have a nice posterior on you can
just kind of estimates you can just plug
that in and so but that's a little bit
in the future right now it's just going
into into the old process where they
were just looking at averages and just
using their domain knowledge
yeah ya know so it was yeah it wasn't
good so we're now with the other day
we're down to 25 minutes that should say
that so now it's fine but yeah I was a
real problem around the model once a
week right now so we should probably we
could run it we we couldn't run it any
more often because it would just like
you know runs for a half a day and or
the whole day and a little bit on the
night yeah so now it's there I'm taking
it to there is getting using the content
of 19 percent solid you're gonna minute
max what you can say the leg baby fake
we can go I think of the max yeah but it
insurance policy that you will have
enough fat Betty orders I guess yeah so
we were always yeah good question like
how do you decide on the band right so
we they can they can view like other
bands too so right now it's it's more
they for some days you you have lower
volume so we are more flexibility built
in so then they can it's not in any way
rich but on some days they're like okay
we're doing a huge marketing push we
should we must not close the store then
we can just okay look at the 99th right
so it's more on that case by case and
but they the ones using it this side
fully for the model but mobile or and
third parts that are stated abusive at
all times good question right now we're
just training whole thing every time so
but like business as usual days those
don't change much but some certain
holidays we get a lot of information
after that whole day right so but we're
thinking a lot about how can we make the
model also more how can we put we need
some element of kind of regime change
maybe and how to model that yeah I'd
like to discuss really love to discuss
how we do that we're thinking about
priors is kind of moving over the day
it's are something like that I know yeah
yeah
Yeah right now we were working on
putting the putting of the marketing
we're working on the data sets of all
the marketing initiatives and everything
we do in the budgets to get that
internal right now it's more like we see
it up okay we have a really wide
posterior now probably because I mean
we've modeled this we use like a dummy
variable for this time of year right and
then we also did some marketing stunts
at that same time and then kind of the
posterior goes like yeah it can happen
like a marketing everything can happen
anytime now right the model so yeah
we're working on an assaulting that's
but right now we we're building the
model and maintaining the model but
we're also in these meetings with the
stakeholders so we can talk about that
and then do some yeah so so but we
really could not at this point just put
it into some automated system and try to
build the ships from that because
because many problems but one that's one
of the problems yeah I know how much
keeping me you guys from the Bears so
maybe we should
[Applause]